MINHAZ KAZI: Data Studio
is Google's next generation
business intelligence and data
visualization platform that
lets you build
scalable serverless
interactive dashboards on
the cloud free of charge.
Hi.
I'm Minhaz Kazi, developer
advocate for Data Studio.
In this video, we'll take a look
at two new exciting features
in Data Studio--
Explorer and Data Blending.
I'll also show you
how you can take
advantage of these
features in Data Studio.
When you're working
with a data set,
you want to first
explore the data.
You want to start with
an overview of the data,
explore it, and
look for insights.
To quote Ben Schneiderman's
visualization mantra,
overview first, zoom and
filter, and details on demand.
So when you're doing more of
an exploratory visualization,
you need the capability
to select exactly the data
you need, [INAUDIBLE] based
on different criteria,
and try different visualizations
to see what makes more sense.
Data Studio Explorer is
a dedicated space for you
to quickly derive
insights from your data
through fast ad-hoc querying.
It is built on top of the
same stack as Data Studio.
So everything
created in Explorer
can be exported into
Data Studio reporting.
And everything visualized
in Data Studio reporting
can be exported into Data
Explorer for quick analysis.
This Explorer feature
becomes more important when
you're working with big data.
For example, in BigQuery.
BigQuery is Google's petabyte
scale data warehouse solution.
In BigQuery you can use SQL
to query terabytes in seconds.
Let's see how you can use
Data Studio's Explorer feature
with a BigQuery data set.
You're going to love this.
Once you have your data in
BigQuery, what can you do?
What if you want to
quickly visualize
the results of your data?
Or what if you have users who
don't know how to write SQL,
but still need to
work with the data?
So here's BigQuery.
And we'll pick a public
dataset from here.
This is the public data set
for Major League Baseball.
And we'll pick this table.
And we will run a sample query.
We'll pick all the fields.
And we'll remove the limit.
And then we'll run the query.
So once the query
is run, then we
can see the results
of the query.
We also have this button
called Exploring Data Studio.
If we click this
button, what will happen
is that Data Studio will
create a direct connection
to the BigQuery table.
And we'll set up the adhoc
visual querying interface
where I can drag and drop
chips that generate the SQL
queries in BigQuery.
So this table contains every
Major League Baseball event
at bat from 2016.
So first, let's say
we want to answer
the question, what is the
venue capacity of each venue?
For that, first we'll
look for the venue cities.
We'll add the city to dimension.
And we'll add the
capacity to the matrix.
And we can see that
these capacities
are very large
numbers because it's
summing up all the results.
So instead of the sum,
we'll pick average.
And now we can see the venue
capacity of these venues.
So let's say we want to
also filter this by state.
So we'll pick the states,
and we'll add the venue state
measure as a filter.
And select California
as the filtering state.
And we'll apply.
And now we can
see all the venues
in California and the
relevant capacities.
This is how easy it is to
use this Explorer interface.
However, I can also switch
this table to a bar chart.
Or I can even switch
this to a geomap.
I can also remove this filter.
And then let's say,
whatever results I have,
I want to put this
in a report and share
that with my stakeholders.
That is also possible to do.
I will save this
Explorer option.
And then I will
take this and put it
into a new Data Studio report.
Data Explorer is 100%
interoperable with Data Studio
reporting.
So I can move
visualizations created here
to Data Studio reporting
with one click.
And now Data Studio is
exporting my visualizations
to this report.
And here you can see the report.
I can now add a
filter for the state.
And then I can share this report
with my other stakeholders
where they can easily
filter and see the results.
If you want to get valuable
insights from your data,
you might bring in data
from different sources.
Then you want to combine,
analyze, and visualize
your combined data as a whole.
When you combine
multiple data sets
based on common parameters,
the visualization
gives you better
context to the data.
For example, you might want
to join your daily sales
data by geographic
region with that region's
daily average temperature to
see how the temperature affected
sales.
This can be useful if
you are, let's say,
an ice cream manufacturer.
Data Studio lets you bring in
data from different sources
and visualize them side by side
on the same dashboard page.
However, the Data
Blending feature
will let you join
those data sets,
and analyze, filter,
and visualize them
in the same visual component.
Let's see how easily Data
Blending works in Data Studio.
In this example, we'll
walk through how easy
it is to blend your
data in Data Studio.
We'll blend your
Google Analytics data
with some public data.
If you want to do
this without blending,
it will require exporting
data from the original system,
like Analytics, using an
API or manual exports,
and then joining that data
in a tool like Google Sheets
or BigQuery.
Using blending, you can
combine the data in Data Studio
and continue to take advantage
of the direct connection
to your data.
To get started, let's assume
you have two data sources.
The first one is the
Google Analytics data
and a set of public data
sets that shows the US
population on a state basis.
So let's say we'll add the
public information first.
We will add the population
public data source.
For dimension, we
will add region.
And for metric, we will
add the population.
So you can see each region
and their population.
So we'll add a
second table where
we'll bring in the
Google Analytics data.
And similarly, over here, we'll
bring in region and also user
count.
So what we want to do is we want
to blend these two data sources
and have one table
where we'll have
the region, the
population, and the users.
And it is very easy to
do that in Data Studio.
What we will do is we'll
select both of the tables.
Right click.
Select Blend Data.
And then Data
Studio will give us
a new table that will have a new
blended data source with both
of these fields present.
So as you can see over here
in this table that is blended,
we have the region, the
population, and the users.
And that is how easy it is
to blend data in Data Studio.
So Data Explorer lets you
quickly generate insights
from your data, in
addition to leveraging
powerful visualizations
in reports.
And Data Blending lets
you join your data
from multiple sources,
and visualize them
in the same component to
provide additional context.
These new features will help you
to get a better understanding
of your data and get actionable
insights in a shorter
time in Data Studio.
Go to datastudio.google.com
and try out these new features
today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]